bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale tout de
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette
édition immobilier des logements
étudiants à la ferme l'association
campus Vert propose cette solution pour
pour aider les jeunes qui rencontrent de
vraies difficultés pour se loger en
île-de-fance des solutions et du nouveau
également pour Promopole la pépinière
d'entreprise de 50 ans en yeline a un
nouveau président elle connaît des
difficultés financières depuis quelques
années son avenir va peut-être changer
c'est ce que nous verrons l'entreprise
de la semaine est placée sous le CIM de
l'innovation H2i est une petite société
d'ingénierie créée par deux retraités et
à l'origine du Boxter une machine à
déminer et puis nous parlerons de
l'avenir de de Promopole et des
difficultés qu'elle rencontrre nous
retrouverons Hotman naserou vous êtes le
nouveau président de Promopole la
pépinière d'entreprise de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline nous reviendrons avec vous
sur la situation actuelle et vos projets
pour la pépinière mais avant cela place
aux informations économiques de la
semaine trouver un logement pour
étudiants à moindre coup cela ressemble
souvent au parcours du combattant
l'association campus vert nouvellement
installée en île-de-fance propose une
solution originale les logements
étudiants à la ferme nous avons
rencontré le premier bénéficiaire
bénéficiaire pardon d'un logement campus
vert en Île-de-France dans les ivelines
à mesir sursène un reportage de yolen
Torz et elodim
moine ça va seulement quelques semaines
qu'ils se connaissent et la complicité
est déjà là étudiant génie industriel
Rémy loue un studio ici dans
l'exploitation céréalière de Patrick
originaire de scè Saint- il découvre
alors l'univers de la campagne j'avais
peur d'habiter au milieu d'un champ
finalement lors de la visite je me suis
rendu compte que j'étais pas non plus en
plein dans la campagne c'est quand même
assez urbain ici à une quinzaine de
minutes en voiture de son campus
universitaire reméy a rapidement sauté
sur l'occasion d'autant plus que le
loyer défie toute concurrence je pay 455
€ pour une surface de 35 m² ça me paraît
pas cher comparé à ce que j'avais pu
trouver sur au niveau de Monte la jolie
ou monte la ville où les prix
commençaient à taper dans les 6 voire
700 €. et pour des surfaces habitables
qui sont nettement inférieures à cell
qui est proposé ici faute de moyens ce
bâtiment était laissé à l'abandon depuis
plus de 30 ans aujourd'hui sur les
240000 € investis pour sa rénovation
près de la moitié a été subventionné par
la région et un programme européen pour
le reste Patrick a fait appel aux
banques l'avantage dans ce type de
d'activité c'est que ce sont des revenus
fixe tous les mois alors que bon
l'agriculture on sait bien que on subit
toujours des situations ou des allé
climatiques qui font que d'unné sur
l'autre on n'est pas sûr d'avoir le même
type de revenu quoi la rencontre entre
les deux a été rendue possible par
l'association campus vert qui met en
relation agriculteur et étudiants depuis
1995 d'abord implanté dans le nordp
decalais avant de s'étendre en Bretagne
puis en Picardie le programme commence à
s'implanter en île-de- France ici à
Montel jolie on vient de démarrer et
on a énormément de demandes d'étudiants
pour pour pouvoir bénéficier d'un
logement à moindre coût aujourd'hui
l'association travaille avec 120
agriculteurs qui logent 530 étudiants
objectif d'ici la fin de l'année loger
70 étudiants supplémentaires à la
ferme Pôle Emploi lance son premier
salon de recrutement en ligne partant du
constat que de nos jours 82 % des foyers
ont accès à Internet la démarche vise à
faciliter la recherche d'emploi et
surtout le contact entre entre les
demandeurs et les entreprises souhaitant
recruter en ce moment du 22 septembre au
5 octobre les entreprises déposent leur
offr et les candidats peuvent ainsi
postuler tout de suite les précisions de
Marianne Casalet directrice de l'agence
pô emploi de
Rambouillet sur ce site en fait lorsque
vous êtes demandeur d'emploi vous
inscrivez donc demandeur d'emploi ou
actif c'est très simple ça se fait en
deux coups de clics de souris là vous
accédez à une page donc vous présentant
les opportunités d'emploi dép par les
entreprises et vous présentant également
des outils pour réussir vos entretiens
dès que vous êtes sur une annonce qui
vous convient vous la sélectionner vous
proposez votre profil et l'employeur la
réceptionne immédiatement en miroir et
lui ça lui permet d'organiser ses
entretiens de recrutement derrière à
partir du 6 octobre à titre indicatif
sur les Yvelines on a deux participants
pour le moment donc qui ont déposé les
offres la mairie de trappe et la base
aérienne de
villeacoublé la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles dans les
evines vient de mettre en place un
espace dédié au porteurs de projets
présents dans le département cette
boutique comme elle est ainsi appelée
propose des informations des conseils et
diagnostics gratuits et payants je vous
propose d'en savoir un peu plus avec
cette interview de Nathalie Bonier
responsable du
projet bien souvent vous avez besoin
d'avoir d' des informations économiques
alors qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
information économique c'est très très
très large ça peut être le coût moyen
d'un mtre carré une surface de
location pour des hangars il y a un
certain nombre d'éléments et
d'indicateurs que nous pouvons donner de
façon relativement fiable à un porteur
de projet qui voudrait s'installer ou à
une entreprise qui veut se développer
sur le
territoire la boutique se trouve dans la
CCI de Versailles elle est ouverte sur
rendez-vous les mardis et jeudi
après-midi de 14h à 16h30 passons tout
de suite à l'entretien de la
semaine
l'entretien de la semaine porte sur
Promopole et son avenir alors Promopole
c'est une pépinière et un village pour
les jeunes entreprises qui souhaite se
développer un support qui aide et
accompagne les débuts des porteurs de
projets en leur louant notamment des
locaux à Saint-Quentin la pépinière
s'est développé sur quatre sites mais le
projet connaît depuis quelques années
une perte d'attractivité c'est pourtant
un concept qui continue de séduire de
nombreuses entrepreneur je vous propose
tout d'abord de découvrir ce sujet afin
de vous rappeler ce qu'est une pépinière
d'entreprise des images ds le di
moine difficile de croire que Promopole
va mal et pourtant entre 2008 et 2012 le
taux d'occupation en mèes carrés sur le
site de Montini lebretonneux est passé
de 90 à 7 % avec ses 9000 m car de
surface locative réparti sur quatre
sites Montini trappe Torz trappe
merisier aiguille en cour la pépinière
compte 120 sociétés en 2014 c'est 11 de
moins qu'en 2012 pourtant le concept de
pépinière est toujours un succès auprès
des jeunes entrepreneurs intégrer une
pépinière était pour nous vraiment
quelque chose de très important pourquoi
parce que pour nous la pépinière c'est
l'échange c'est discuter avec avec les
les personnes qui qui sont en charge de
cette pépinière pour nous apporter
justement un support lorsqu'on en a
besoin et c'est aussi intégré en tout
cas pour Promopole intégrer le bassin de
cquanttin en Yveline bassin économique
qui au niveau de l'Île-de-France est
très important haute croquet et Amélie
asfo sont les directrices de pop r les
deux jeunes femmes ont monté ensemble
cette société de conseil en relation
humaine il y a un an après un passage
dans la pépinière de louvciienne elles
ont choisi celle de Promopole à montinil
le breteneux pour augmenter leur
activité on a la chance de profiter de
plusieurs espaces salles de réunion des
salles un peu plus grandes suivant le
type de public qu'on accueille et puis
tout équipé du matériel que ce soit des
paperbards ou bien rétroprojecteur et
cetera un soutien technique des conseils
pour se développer économiquement mais
pas seulement la pépinière permet
d'agrandir son réseau et de faire naître
de nombreux contacts ou donc on va
déerès bien au-delà si elle est là je
pense que ça va être bien manger ouais
oua ouais avec plaisir créer son
entreprise c'est un peu comme être en
recherche d'emploi c'està-dire qu'on est
face à à beaucoup de de de questions et
puis beaucoup de démarches aussi à faire
le fait d'être en pép
ça faorise l'échange très clairement ça
favorise aussi la rencontre parce queah
travailler de chez soi ou travailler
dans petits espaces isolé on n pas
toujours
l'opportunitéotman nasrou remplace Jean
Gendron ancien président de Promopole un
état des lieux et un audit financier ont
été lancés à la rentrée 2014 pour tenter
de remettre à niveau la
pépinière parlons maintenant de promopo
et son avenirotman bonjour bonjour et
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau vous
êtes vous être le nouveau président de
Promopole et également chef d'entreprise
puisque vous êtes à la tête de Citizen
place une entreprise qui soutient
l'action associative en France en
développant des outils innovants c'est
ca c'est cela alors pour commencer
pouvez-nous vous pouvez-vous nous faire
un petit état des lieux de la situation
de Promopole bien écoutez merci de votre
invitation la situation de Promopole
dont on hérite suite aux élections
effectivement municipale avec
l'alternance qui a connu la communauté
d'agglomération de ctins en Yveline est
une situation il faut rendre des comptes
et les choses telles qu'elles sont
dégradées dégradé sur le plan financier
c'est un héritage effectivement qui est
un petit peu lourd à porter puisque
c'est un outil qui quand même existe
depuis
1987 qui rencontre vous l'avez dit
quelques difficultés depuis des années
qui sont à la fois structurelles et
conjoncturelles j'auris peut-être
l'occasion d'en dire un mot c'est un
outil qui continue aujourd'hui
d'accueillir plus de 120 entreprises qui
joue son rôle quand même c'est l'une des
plus grandes pépinières de France et
aussi à la mesure des ambitions
économiques du territoire moi ce que je
souhaite dans la situation que connaît
Promopole à cette situation difficile
que je vous décris c'est que ce ne soi
pas les chefs d'entreprise qui soient
les pris en otage de cette situation je
pense que Promopole peut-être sauvé et
mérite une stratégie qui soit réellement
de remise à niveau à la hauteur des
ambitions du territoire comme je le
disais comment peut-on expliquer cette
baisse d'attractivité parce que bien sûr
il y a la crise économique qui qui joue
mais il y a d'autres raisons vous pouvez
m'en dire un peu plus effectivement vous
l'avez rappelé nous avons de demander un
audit financier tout d'abord pour bien
comprendre la situation à Promopole cet
audit fait apparaître un certain nombre
d'éléments de gestion d'erreur de
gestion manifeste il m'appartient pas de
les
qualifier juridiquement le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui promopol se retrouve dans
une situation financière délicate
justement vous pouvez me rappeler le
montant du déficit alors Promopole son
résultat comptable 2013 il est de 250000
€ de perte tout à fait alors il faut
savoir qu'une pépinière d'entreprise
c'est une activité qui est difficile à
être pour être équilibré mais pour
autant il y a à Promopole des erreurs de
gestion des des équilibres qui n'ont pas
été trouvés et je plaide pour ma part
pour une stratégie de remise à niveau de
Promopole sur trois points essentiels
premier c'est qu'il faut reconfigurer le
modèle c'est qu'on a faire aujourd'hui
une pépinière qui n'est plus forcément
compétitive qui n'a quasiment pas été
réformé depuis depuis très longtemps
depuis qu'il existe quasiment le
deuxième point c'est qu'il faut
s'engager sur une trajectoire financière
extrêmement précise avec une gestion
rigoureuse je pense que Promopole qui
est une société doit être dirigé euh par
une gestion de chef d'entreprise et pas
simplement comme une administration et
puis le trisième point c'est un nouveau
dispositif d'accompagnement qui soit à
la mesure de ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui parce qu'on on doit le
meilleur quand même aux entreprises du
territoire qui vivent un contexte
extrêmement compliqué à ces conditions
si ces conditions sont réunies le
sauvtage de Promopole est tout à fait
possible et moi c'est un peu la la
feuille de route que j'ai que j'ai que
j'ai reçu et je souhaite la mener à
terme si bien sûr les options que je
propose sont retenu alors comment la
configurer justement alors il y a il y a
il y a plusieurs points j'aurais
l'occasion d'en présenter le détails
dans un document public parce que je
pense que puisqu'il y a de l'argent
public c'est une société d'économie
mixte dans laquelle la comité
d'agglomération est actionnaire il faut
aussi rendre des comptes aux citoyens et
puis aux chefs d'entreprise encore une
fois qui ont l'immense mérite de créer
des emplois et de faire vivre ce pays et
je pense qu'il faut les rassurer aussi
sur ce qui est fait de cet argent et
cetera donc il y a un ensemble de
mesures qu'on va proposer il faut
remettre à plat le modèle économique la
grille tarifaire il y a des
reconfiguration à faire sur le foncier
sur l'immobilier sur les actifs de
Promopole et puis il y a surtout une
gestion extrêmement R ouruse à avoir je
crois que ce gâi d'argent public a assez
duré on est en capacité avec cette
pépinière de revenir à l'équilibre et
d'en faire réellement un
outil de meilleure qualité qui soit
réellement à la pointe de ce qui peut se
faire maintenant il faut aussi qu'il y
ait la volonté politique bien entendu
que cette stratégie soit retenue la
décision ne m'appartient pas je la
soumets en tant que président de
Promopole et je souhaite qu'elle soit
adoptée par les élus en charge de cette
question vous me le rappeliez justement
donc les la structure est financée aussi
donc par par les financements publics
est-ce que cela a un sens s en cette
période de de crise et de baisse de
dotation aux
collectivités je crois que ça a un sens
je crois qu'au contraire dans la période
qu'on connaît qui une période très
difficile sur le plan économique
l'action publique en terme de
développement économique est essentielle
je pense notamment à l'action des
territoires et d'un territoire aussi
riche merveilleux dynamique que celui de
5 en y maintenant ça ne veut pas dire
que l'argent public doit combler des
fautes de gestion manifestes ou des
erreurs qui se sont accumulé au fil des
ans ou encore des mauvaises options
stratégiques je pense cet argent public
il doit être un levier pour permettre à
une structure comme Promopole de se
redresser avec des engagements
extrêmement clairs avec les meilleures
normes de gestion qui puisse se faire en
la matière je crois qu'on le doit aux
chefs d'entreprise qui n'attendent pas
de notre part aujourd'hui en tant qu'élu
à la simplement des des vœux pieux ou ou
des paroles mais des actes très forts et
aujourd'hui l'arbitrage qui sera rendu
donc dans une dizaine de jours il doit
être un arbitrage en faveur du
développement économique du territoire
cette pépinière là elle est essentielle
et l'argent public là-dessus a tout à
fait sa place à condition encore une
fois qu'il soit utiliser et c'est
l'engagement qui est le mien dans les
meilleures conditions de gestion est-ce
que selon vous ce serait possible de
trouver d'autres sources de financement
pour
Promopole alors les pépinières
d'entreprise structurellement ont
justement un modèle économique un petit
peu compliqué à trouver c'est ce qu'on
disait et souvent elles font aussi vous
l'avez dit une activité de village
c'està-dire qu'on héberge également des
entreprises qui sont plus mûes qui ont
moins besoin de l'aspect accompagnement
souplesse réactivité et servicees
mutualisés que propose une pépinière et
c'est comme ça qu'une Promopole peut
aussi retrouver un équilibre d'ailleurs
propole réalise 100000 € de chiffre
d'affaires tous les ans qui est en fait
l'encaissement des loyers des
différentes sociétés qui sont hébergées
donc des sources de financement qui ne
sont pas entièement public elles
existent déjà et j'ai envie de dire que
sur une société comme Promopole encore
heureux l'argent public est une part
marginale de son financement simplement
du fait des des de la gestion précédente
dont on hérite mais encore une fois les
les responsables d'entreprises n' sont
pas voilà N sont pas comptable il est
important euh que l'argent public
revienne à porter un petit peu le
financement qu'il faut pour qu'un
redressement réel et tout à fait
faisable puisse se faire euh justement
est-ce que les pépinières d'entreprise
vous voilà en tant que que chef
d'entreprise est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est encore attractif est-ce que ça
marche toujours pour voilà les jeunes
entrepreneurs est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours décidés à à aller vers ce
concept je pense que c'est un concept
essentiel je crois qu'il n'y a rien de
plus compliqué peut-être que de créer
une entreprise de zéro si je dire c'est
une aventure incroyable mais au combien
difficile he dans un pays où il peut
aussi y avoir une inertie une crainte du
changement notamment dans le contexte
qu'on vit et chef entreprise que je vois
au quotidien notamment à Promopole ont
besoin réellement de cette réactivité on
en parlait dans le reportage de ce
dispositif d'accompagnement de cette
souplesse qui leur permet de de grandir
au fur à mesure de leur activité compris
sur la surface qu'elles occupent je
crois que c'est essentiel les équipes de
promopo qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas
démérité ces dernières années malgré des
difficultés qui réalisent au quotidien
un travail assez exceptionnel auprès des
des chefs
d'entreprise sont en mesure d'apporter
un accompagnement qu'on ne peut pas
trouver dans l'immobilier de bureau
traditionnel et c'est pour ça qu'on a au
contraire un grand développement des
pépinières d'entreprise sur Paris sur le
plateau de sa clé autour de serg
Pontoise et cetera et je crois qu'à
sa-anttin en Yveline on a besoin d'un
outil qui soit réellement au niveau
Promopole peut le devenir encore faut-il
qu'il y ait bien sûr la volonté de le
faire mais une pépinière d'entreprise
c'est essentiel si on veut réellement
continuer à créer des emplois et à
favoriser l'innovation en France votre
statut de chef d'entreprise est-ce que
c'est c'est ça qui vous a poussé à vous
à vous présenter à la présidence de
Promopole
oui que de Promopole est difficile on le
disait tout à l'heure c'est une
situation qui était connue face à ça on
a deux attitudes on peut s'en laver les
mains se dire que de toute façon vaut
mieux pas s'en occuper que c'est un
héritage passé et qu'il faut quelque
part simplement faire de la politique
là-dessus moi je suis un jeune élu je ne
le crois pas je pense que ce des chef
d'entreprise c'est des solutions
pragmatiques et pas de la politique
simplement politicienne donc à partir de
là l'autre option c'était de se
retrousser les manches d'être conscient
des difficultés qu'il y a un héritage
qui n'est pas acceptable il va falloir
le dire aussi le moment venu mais qu'il
faut aussi pouvoir proposer des
solutions et c'est vrai qu'en tant que
chef d'entreprise j'avais le le défit de
redresser cette entreprise qui qui est
Promopole c'est la mission queont bien
voulu me confier le président de
l'agglomération Michel og vice-président
en charge des affaires économiques
Jean-Michel forous je vous en remerci et
je souhaite la mener à terme si les
arbitrages me sont favorables sur cette
question là très bien merci je vous
propose tout de suite de passer au
chiffre de pardon à la question de la
semaine donc la question de la semaine
en fait porte voilà sur les entreprises
nous avons de demander aux ivelinois
quelles sont selon eux les solutions
pour aider les jeunes
entreprises que les
déclaration soi faite facilement
rapidement qui ait pas trop de de
documents administratifs à remplir
diminuer les charges déjà à la base pour
qu'il puisse Baucher qui est des aides
faciles de la part des banques des prêts
RB des gens instruits plein de diplômes
mais qui s'env à l'étranger et puis qui
nous aideent pas voilà il faut prendre
au sérieux tous les les gens qui ont des
bonnes idées en France qui est des zones
de pépinières de jeunes de jeunes
entreprises déjà baisser les impôts
toutes les charges sociales qu'ils ont
il lève les manches ils prennent des
conseils chez les anciens et qui est
également la mise en place d'un sorte de
tutora réaction à ce que vous venez
d'entendre ben écoutez j'aimerais que
vous enfin ces citoyens vous avez
interrogé ont à peu près tout dit et
c'est triste de voir effectivement que
nos élites politiques le plus souvent
sont très éloignés de ces ces aspects là
effectivement un promopo c'est ce que je
disais on ne peut pas gérer promopol
comme une administration ce n'est pas ce
que les chefs d'entreprises attendent
donc là je crois que tout est dit je
crois que réellement là-dessus que ce
soit sur la baisse des charges pour les
entreprises que ce soit sur les
dispositifs d'accompagnement que ce soit
sur les expérimentations qu'on peut
imaginer je crois que sur le financement
des entreprises et là aussi on a
d'autres outils très intéressants la
maison de entreprise avec le fond
initiative 501
tout est dit maintenant il y a plus qu'à
le faire et je crois que réellement nous
en tout cas nouvelle majorité à la
comité d'agglomération ce sont on a
attendu sur des actes et puis sur le
plan national le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'on est aujourd'hui très éloigné
de ces solutions là bien merci Hotman
nasrou merci aussi d'être venu sur notre
plateau je vous dis au revoir et tout de
suite c'est le moment de passer au
chiffres de la
semaine cette semaine le chiffre de la
semaine concerne l'emploi moins0 0,7 %
c'est le pourcentage de demandeurs
d'emploi en moins enregistré entre le
mois de juillet et le mois d'août 2014
pour le département des Yvelines un
pourcentage semblable à celui de
l'Île-de-France le nombre d'inscrits en
catégorie A s'établi à
64 560 en Île-de-France soit 4450
personnes en moins par rapport au mois
de juillet 2014 une donnée positive mais
qu'il convient de de relativiser car sur
un an le chômage en île defance est en
hausse de 6 8
% l'entreprise de la semaine s'appelle
H2i et elle a conçu un engin
télécommandé capable de déminer les
mines antipersonnelles alors à l'origine
de ce projet de retraité de Montini le
Bretonneux reconverti en entrepreneur
nous avons rencontré Anne sandR l'un des
l'un des deux fondateurs pardon de la
Société des images signées elodim moan
et un montage de Romain
rpini robot futuriste mini rouleau
compresseur ni l'un ni l'autre cette
machine télécommandée est un engin de
déminage ça actionne le le détonateur
puisque'en fait ça appuie comme si
c'était une personne qui montait sur la
mine donc ça la fait exploser avec ces
deux tonnes de fer le Boxter résiste à
une explosion de 400 g de TNT à
l'origine de ce projet André Hans
ex-ingénieur en recherche et
développement dans l'industrie
automobile et rubben guimion également
ingénieur les deux hommes amis de
longuees date se sont lancés dans
l'aventure une fois la retraite mais pas
par hasard en décembre 2005 monsieur
guimant rentit d'Arménie et il était ému
puisqu'il avait quelqu'un de sa famille
qui avait sauté sur le mine donc on a
décidé de travailler ensemble sur ce
projet avec les conflits actuels on pose
plus de mines qu'en en aôre il faut
savoir que sur entre la Turquie et la
Syrie il y a un barrage de mines de 500
km 2 ans de recherche plus tard les
ingénieurs déposent de brevets et
commencent à demander des financements
le projet séduit auoséo innovation et le
crit deux entités publiques financent le
projet l'aboutissement d'un travail
colossal pour ce cptiagénire passionné
par son métier j'avais pas de problème
financier qui justifiait une poursuite
d'activité mais il y a un côté ludique
hein donc c'est l'occasion de rester en
contact avec le métier de faire des
salons de voir des gens d'avoir comment
dire une vie professionnelle le
prototype réalisé va être commercialisé
par la société allemandue BOMAG un
leader mondial du matériel de travaux
publics il manque encore quelques
homologations au Boxter pour être vendu
prix de l'engin 150000 € c'est un des
moins coûteux du marché je pense que les
commandes viendront très vite puisque
c'est un engin qui peut intéresser aussi
bien les civils au niveau de
l'humanitaire que des militaires qui
veulent des miner des terrains où ils
ont des activités 10000 Boxter ont déjà
été précommandés Handicap International
fait partie des intéressés la vie
d'entrepreneur ne fait que commencer
pour André qui est encore bien loin de
la retraite
notre zoom de la semaine est consacré au
métiers de coiffeur la coiffure est le
le deuxème pardon secteur de l'artisanat
en France si la profession a été
impactée par la crise de nouvelles
tendan se développe comme notamment la
coiffure à domicile qui connaît un
certain succès nous avons rencontré
plusieurs coiffeurs dans les ivelines
travaillant en salon et à domicile pour
observer les différentes facettes de ce
métier William l et Romain rpin
vous passez avec un coiffeur de
préférence merci beaucoup auevir tout à
l'heure prendre soin de sa clientèle
avir le sens de l'esthétique le métier
de coiffeur requiert beaucoup
d'attention mlanie exerce à versaill
pour elle la technique et l'écoute sont
les deux qualités essenti d'un bon
professionnel coiffeuse depuis l'âge de
15 ans elle a travaillé pour la
télévision et également comme formatrice
en école de coiffure va mieux que ce
soit une vocation quelque chose qu'on a
en soi et un plaisir réel parce que
c'est pas spécialement des métiers
manuels donc il faut que ça reste
quelque chose qu'on a en soi quoi ça
s'apprend pas spécialement on est formé
pour apprendre des coupes tout ça les
bases mais il faut vraiment y mettre du
sien et avoir les créations être très
créatif en France 37000 jeunes suivent
cette formation qui dure en moyenne 2
ans un cap est nécessaire mais il est
possible de poursuivre avec un beep ou
d'autres spécialisations si un coiffeur
perçoit le SMIC à ses débuts le secteur
recrute 150 emplois à pourvoir sur le
seul département des evel comme la mode
le milieu évolue rapidement le coiffeur
se doit d'être au fait des dernières
nouveautés il faut qu'il soit un minimum
disponible ouvert à la formation même
s'il pens être très compétent on pense
tous l'être mais c'est un métier qui
bouge beaucoup c'est c'est un métier qui
évolue et par les formations on se met à
jour régulièrement pour devenir patron
de son salon comme Laurent il est
recommmenté d'avoir un brevet de
maîtrise diplôme délivré par la Chambre
des Métiers 80000 établissements et
100000 sal en France le secteur est
attractif même s'il subit la crise la
fréquentation et la production baissent
4,7 visites chez le coiffeur par an
contre 6 en 2008 pour les femmes la
situation n'est pas aisée mais
travailler en salon n'est pas la seule
possibilité télévision défilé de mode
cinéma les alternatives sont nombreuses
et l'une d'entre elles fonctionne
particulièrement bien bonjour ça va et
toi Carlotta via Montini le Bretonneux
elle est coiffeuse à domicile depuis un
an et demi comme ils sont 15000 en
France à avoir choisi de se déplacer en
tant qu'auto-entrepreneuse elle gère son
emploi du temps et les tarifs pratiqués
sont moins onéreux le concept plaît
autant au prestataires qu'aux clients je
pensais pas que j'aurais autant de
demandes et en réalité je pensais
également que j'allais avoir plutôt des
personnes âgées qui allaient me
contacter et en réalité j'ai des
clientes tout à fait jeunes dynamique
avec des familles notamment des enfants
et Commons pas le temps d'aller chez
coiffeur et perdre une une après-midi
une matinée entière bah il font appel à
moi contrairement à la plupart des
auto-entrepreneurs qui investissent en
moyenne 500 € Carlotta a dû acheter tout
son matériel de coiffure ainsi qu'une
voiture attendre un an avant de se
rémunérer mais elle ne regrette pas son
salaire est similaire à celui qu'elle
avait en salon mais sa nouvelle
condition lui offre plus de proximité
avec la clientèle et surtout une
meilleure qualité de vie le fait d'être
à son propre compte c'est c'est génial
vous vous êtes libre vous quelque part
vous votre expérience enfin prime je
pense que j'ai enfin trouvé mon créneau
le nombre de coiffeurs à domicile a
doublé en 7 ans il représente
aujourd'hui 20 % du secteur pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 300 millions
d'euros c'est la fin de notre émission
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi et
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
filcho je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée